news now breaking news alert
well breaking news this afternoon a very
concerning day for many parents after a
local high school is put on hard
lockdown thank you so much for joining
us here at 4 30 i'm christian casa and
i'm kirstjen joyce police were called to
desert oasis high school around noon
today that's near mountains edge parkway
in rainbow sally jadamillo joins us live
sally this is a terribly frightening
call to get as a parent word of a gun on
campus
yes a very scary situation for those
parents waiting outside and for the
students and staff inside of desert
oasis some students told me once they
heard lockdown on the speaker they
panicked police did arrest a female
student now several parents became aware
of a student who reportedly had a weapon
in school a mother we spoke to was at
home when her son texted her saying to
please call police when she couldn't
find any information on what was going
on she decided to head to the school
i have five kids in total so
this is my second one in high school i
still have three more kids to go
we're looking into a different school
for my daughter
other parents told me out here that they
are concerned about the ongoing issue
with guns in schools and what can be
done according to the school district as
of january there had been a total of 58
possession of weapon reports now back
out live the principal at desert oasis
did send out letters informing parents
of what had happened here at the school
and he did mention that safety was their
number one priority reporting live in
the southwest salihadamiyo live local
now